[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dalles de tv 78 se poursuit à
l'université des mairies et durant les
20 prochaines minutes nous allons parler
d'offre de santé et de déserts médicaux
avec mes trois invités didier baichère
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député de la
première circonscription des yvelines
vous avez notamment vous étiez notamment
vice-président de la commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur l'égal accès
aux soins sur les dispositifs de lutte
contre les déserts médicaux
philippe benassaya bonjour bonjour mr de
bois d'arcy conseiller départemental et
président d'un générique vous
accompagner les communes dans leurs
projets d'urbanisme notamment dans le
développement des maisons médicales et
michel poireau bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes adjoint au maire de triel sur
seine en charge de l'urbanisme et vous
avez mené le projet de maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire henri dunant sur
votre commune un établissement qui sera
inaugurée en décembre 2019
oui voilà la date est pratiquement fixée
ce sera le jeudi avant les vacances de
noël voilà donc un établissement que
vous vous allez nous on vous en parlait
la manière dont vous avez construit ce
projet depuis 2014
alors commençons d'abord par un
diagnostic dans les yvelines on compte
aujourd'hui plus de 2000 médecins
libéraux dont la moitié sont des
généralistes un âge moyen de 53 ans pour
les généralistes de 64 ans et demi pour
les spécialistes de nombreuses communes
sont placés par l' agence régionale de
santé en zone d'intervention prioritaire
c'est des communes qui sont reconnus
comme désert déserts médicaux des
situations différentes en fonction des
territoires zones urbaines et zones
rurales
alors il ya ces chiffres et puis il ya
les conséquences sur le terrain je
commence avec vous didier baichère
comment vous ressentez vous sur le
territoire des yvelines
le phénomène de désert médical avec je
pense qu'il ya pas une ville dans les
yvelines vous allez souvent désert
médical on pense aux zones rurales
excitant mais même les grandes villes
très dense moi je pense à versailles en
particulier sont des déserts médicaux
je vous donne juste un chiffre comme ça
qui me frappe toujours quand on regarde
le nombre de médecins pour 100000
habitants entre l'ile-de-france les
yvelines et le reste de la france
vous avez 200 85 ans jeudi médecins ces
médecins et kinés fin tous les
paramédicaux 285 pour les yvelines
1 400 sur l'ile-de-france et 380 surface
de la france donc les yvelines est un
des départements les plus mal notés en
capacité médicale aujourd'hui alors
qu'on a potentiellement enfin gérant il
fait bon vivre dans les yvelines
donc on voit bien que si des décisions
comme la suppression du numerus clausus
et plein d'autres on aura probablement
l'occasion d'en parler du projet de
m'attendre ma santé 2022 ne sont pas
mises en place
on aura beau construire et c'est vrai
que le département fait un effort
financier considérable pour aller
construire des maisons de santé mais les
murs ne suffiront pas à dire qu'on
n'arrivera pas à remplir les maisons de
santé parce qu'on va manquer de médecins
deux paramédicaux et c'est donc le
l'enjeu aujourd'hui il est de former
plus de médecins et puis aussi je crois
de repenser la manière de faire la
médecine et là il y aura des enjeux
je pense au niveau des municipalités
soit un enjeu très important des
élections municipales de savoir comment
une agglomération à un moment donné que
coordonner ses soins avec l'ensemble du
dispositif médecine de ville l'hôpital x
ça c'est un enjeu de ma santé 2022 by
benzaie je le disais dans l'introduction
le conseil départemental s'est saisie de
ce problème
comment est ce que vous avez de nombreux
maires qui vous contactent justement
pour les aider énormément ce le député
le disait et un instant c'est vrai que
c'est très très sa sujet de santé
publique mais la foi aussi un sujet de
l'attractivité du territoire
le problème de la santé est un problème
de 2,2 d'enjeux territoriale on est on
est confronté aujourd'hui à non
seulement un désert médical en milieu
urbain en milieu surtout rurales aussi
et il fallait surtout apporter une
réponse rapide parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya pénurie de médecins il n'y a
pas tellement de pénurie de médecins
généralistes france dans les yvelines
mais énormément de spécialistes
d'infirmiers énormément d'infirmier il
ya tous ces sujets là et il a fallu
apporter une réponse je sais pas si je
dois apporter la réponse tout de suite
si j'ai le temps
on a peut-être un peu le temps mais
c'est vrai que l'effort du département
très très important puisqu'on amis quand
même 32 millions d'euros sur la table en
2017 lors du premier appel à projets et
on parlera peut-être dans le détail de
toutes les maisons médicales que l'on
finance aujourd'hui soit via le
directement le département soit on est
dans les communes
donc on a énormément d'appels à projets
énormément de projets et ça c'est quand
même une réponse rapide à ce problème
on viendra justement sur l'action du
gouvernement du
département et du gouvernement aussi on
va évoquer le plan gouvernemental ma
santé 2022 mais d'abord michel poireau
comment vous avez vous êtes saisis du
problème en 2014 par rapport à ce
phénomène dans votre commune à triel sur
seine vient tout simplement dès le soir
des fades et le soir du deuxième tour
des élections municipales un triller loi
que je connais bien n'est pas
suffisamment manifestement est venu
m'entretenir de toute l'assistance qu'il
apportait à sa compagne depuis des
années et de la crainte partagée par
beaucoup de trier loi dans la même
situation de voir les médecins
disparaître effectivement la situation
des yvelines où vous l'avez rappelé à
juste titre est inférieur nous avons une
moins forte densité de soignants que
dans d'autres départements mais triel se
situe en dessous de tous les critères
yvelinois est bon je dirais c'est comme
l'élève qui est juste en dessous des
moyennes partout au final ça fait un
très mauvais bulletin est donc à triel
c'est bien ce qui est annonce qui s'y
étaient annoncés juste ce qui manque de
triel de radars dont 2,7 of pas de
soignants pour les triellois donc un
besoin et puis une annonce de grands
départs qui arrive et qu'elle arrive et
les uns derrière les autres et il était
temps de faire quelque chose pour que la
commune soit un peu plus attrayante pour
de jeunes professionnels venir
s'installer
c'est ça la problématique aussi c'est
que beaucoup de médecins partent à la
retraite et ne sont pas remplacés
un problème le gouvernement l'a saisie
de cette manière en tout cas il ya un
problème de formation peut-être
et justement que de lancer plus
rapidement sur le terrain les jeunes et
notamment le développement de stage et
la fin du numerus clausus le numerus
clausus bon déjà c'est quelque chose à
la fin du numéro sous le suçon va faire
qu'on pourra former plus de médecins
mais avec un effet qui sera dans dix ans
donc ce qui est important aujourd'hui
c'est d'arriver à intégrer dans les
projets de maisons de santé
pluriprofessionnelle ou quand on dit
pluriprofessionnelle s'est pas
uniquement des médecins généralistes un
cd qui n'essaie des éthiciens des
psychologues d'infirmières arrivé à
intégrer en fait des étudiants qui vont
avoir un angle d'apprentissage de leur
métier qui n'est pas que l'hôpital
on a eu tendance jusqu'à maintenant
informés et socialement des médecins à
travers un cursus hospitalier et donc
quand vous vous retrouvez seul
enfin exercer la médecine générale vous
voyez pas forcément les avantages une
maison pluriprofessionnelle c'est
plusieurs professionnels de santé donc
un peu comme dans un hôpital finalement
et qui va donner enfin en tout cas c'est
l'engagement qu'on essaye de faire enfin
de susciter va donner envie à plus de
jeunes d'aller vers la filière médecine
généraliste
je voudrais dire aussi que les ces
maisons pluriprofessionnelle c'est aussi
un projet politique par exemple de
montigny le bretonneux
si vous avez aujourd'hui une des plus
abouties en tout cas on sens
pluriprofessionnelle de la rs de maisons
de santé
c'est parce que nicolas à bouillon qui a
déjà de très nombreuses années avait eu
cette vision de la santé est un élément
extrêmement importante de la politique
de la ville et les villes qui se sont
préoccupés très tôt de cette
problématique de santé peuvent
aujourd'hui avant des maisons fleuries
professionnels de santé mature et qui
vont répondre à un besoin des des
habitants ce n'est pas qu'un problème de
mur j'insiste parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
maisons de santé malheureusement qui
sont construites avec des aides diverses
et il n'y a pas de médecin à l'intérieur
allez que vous parliez des communes qui
saisissent de ce problème mais il ya
aussi le département d'ici à 2022 le
département va investir vous l'avez déjà
10 à 1,32 million d'euros pour
construire des maisons médicales alors
construire des maisons médicales pour
les communes mais c'est aussi des
maisons médicales qui vont appartenir
directement au département c'est ça on a
retenu vingt projets je crois en 2017 il
y en a dix qui est porté directement par
le département donc appartenant
département et 10 avec une aide
financière aux communes et il faut
savoir que sur ces 10 il y en a enfin
sur ces vingt projets il y en a neuf qui
sont installés en communes rurales ben
bonnel etc etc
il faut savoir aussi ce qu'on disait un
petit moment c'est que le métier de
médecin aussi a changé les attentes du
médecin change
le médecin de campagne où le médecin
famille vin est en train de disparaître
aujourd'hui le président larcher le
disait ce matin en saône et loire la
saône-et-loire à salarier 37 médecin
donc ça veut dire qu'on est en train de
plus en plus de changer le statut du
médecin qui vient dans nos communes on
le reçoit
moi je suis mère aussi on reçoit ils me
disent moi je vais être salarié sais pas
je sais pas si c'est une généralité mais
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il y a
maintenant ce souci qui est très
important je reviens sur les vingt
projets
et puis près sur les sur les 20 projets
c'est que ce sont des projets ambitieux
on a inauguré il ya quelques mois la
maison médicale d'aubergenville c'est
plus de 380 7000 euros de
l'investissement c'est quand même quand
même important mais sur partagé entre la
rs les communes le département
mahut uniquement des médecins
généralistes spécial deux sages-femmes
et absolument c'est vrai voilà donc
voila voila une action du département et
voilà surtout des réponses précises à ce
sujet et on voit très bien et mon
collègue du département l'expliquent
très très bien c'est que au delà encore
une fois du soutien financement et des
murs et la transformation du métier de
soignant donc le on le voit alors donc
vous avez des trucs trop technique mais
sur le j'ai acheté sud est sûre j'ai
acheté nord en fait la coordination
entre l'hôpital et la médecine de ville
est extrêmement importante parce que
cette continuité
c'est un parterre de santé aussi parce
que c'est complémentaire avec la
question des déserts mito finalement
parce que dans des zones rurales
finalement les patients non pas du coup
de rendez vous directement avec le
médecin et ils vont aller aux urgences
et c'est là où on a le phénomène aussi
de saturation des références on
reviendra justement sur cette question
complémentaire
michel poireau on voit que le
département vous a aidé un pour
développer bien sûr mais 1,7 et
pluridisciplinaire mais comment pour les
mères qui sont présents et pour les élus
qui sont présents aujourd'hui ici
comment vous avez fait un grand
concrètement comment vous avez fait pour
monter ce projet depuis 2014
bon on a fait beaucoup de choses et qui
illustre les progrès au précédent donc
tout d'abord on a travaillé en étroite
collaboration avec les médecins
on a on a réuni ses elle n'aurait jamais
arrivé les 40
on a invité les 46 professionnels de
santé triellois on en a réuni une
trentaine dans une salle dans les
quelques mois qui ont suivi on avait dit
cette lettre d'engagement
donc qui permettait de démarrer l'un des
futurs retraités
c'est vraiment attelé à la tâche avec
moi entre autres péripéties on est allé
jusqu'à tenir salon à la faculté de
médecine à saint quentin en yvelines
donc lors d'une manifestation des
étudiants
imaginez un congrès et vous avez les
exposants et donc nous étions nous
étions avec 28 autres commune yvelinoise
signer dès 1100 ça vous ramène à
beaucoup de modestie sur l'attraction de
votre ville et or qui plus est quand
nous avons appris qu'il y avait une
autre salle dans laquelle il y avait
autant de communes du val d'oise qui
portaient leurs projets nous avons fait
des contacts et là se passe avec
suffisamment d'un terne et encore que si
certains sont venus à triel mais c'est
ou encore la carte bien sûr mais c'est
loin
non mais nous avons rencontré aussi et
pour appréhender le propos tout à
l'heure des collègues qui avaient déjà
une maison médicale vide donc la maison
médicale est un moyen c'est une
condition nécessaire pour attirer des
professionnels
ceci dit elle n'est pas forcément
suffisante et il y avait un pari est en
tout cas ce pari si nous n'avions pas
une équipe médicale mobiliser pour faire
venir d'autres collègues plus jeunes et
donc démontrer la volonté d'un exercice
pluridisciplinaire d'un projet de santé
pour la ville la municipalité à être
tout seul je crois qu'elle ne serait pas
arrivé il ya un acteur clef un
cellulaire ps qui vous accompagne aux
siens
les élus locaux les maires doivent
contacter le rps pour être accompagné
dans ces projets là alors à tous niveaux
donc déjà la crédibilité du maire pour
rassembler tous les professionnels de
santé
certaines mais lui rps ils ont la
méthode ils ont l'expérience ils ont le
savoir-faire
donc depuis depuis fin 2014
je dirais qu'à chaque étape on a pu
s'appuyer sur le savoir-faire de l'ue
rps
donc en termes encore une fois de deux
méthodes que ce soit tant dans
l'animation du groupe de professionnels
de santé ensuite dans la définition du
projet avec les professionnels de santé
et puis l'architecte et aujourd'hui
encore c'est dans la dans la fin des
travaux on a toujours du rps qui veille
au grain si je peux dire et puis bien
entendu vous avez fait allusion au
dispositif de la région du département
de l'état de la rs mais toutes ces
adresses
ben lui rps nous les a présentés à la
technique de montage du dossier
j'avoue que c'est alors ça s'est pas
fait tout seul sa tâche d'actes clé pour
les mères entre quizz vous venez ses
difficultés
oui le manque de médecins sur leur
terrain sûr on a eu quelques promoteurs
spécialiste de la maison de santé qui
sont venus nous vendre d'abord à savoir
faire immobilier mais ça or le pf nous
avait aidés sur l'immobilier ce n'est
pas le sujet mais donc le rps
enfin pour nous était la clé de la
réussite de ce projet je passe à une
autre question des celliers parce que
michel poireau a cité plusieurs
collectivités région département commune
philippe benassaya je me tourne vers
vous c'est une idée qui a émergé c'est
pierre bédier qui en parlait de
départementaliser la compétence santé
aujourd'hui qui est peut-être un peu
trop centralisée même au niveau régional
la rs l' agence régionale de santé
en quoi départementalisée cette
compétence serait pertinent et bien je
vais vous faire une idée vous raconter
une anecdote un exemple je suis
président d'une agence qui s'appelle un
générique est une agence des deux
communes rurales une animaux comme on
dit avant c'était l'état qu'il faisait
maintenant c'est le département qui le
fait on est au plus près des mers et on
est au plus près des projets que portent
les communes rurales
je pense qu'on peut peut-être réfléchir
un départementalisation des questions de
santé parce que plus on va et plus on va
se rapprocher du terrain
je prends pas compte de l'appel à
projets que l'on a lancé en 2017 c'est
pas simplement ouvrir des maisons
médicales c'est aussi de l'aide au
secrétariat enseignement aussi c'est
l'accompagnement pour les jeunes
médecins
c'est une offre qui est incroyable
jamais un département n'a autant investi
sur les problèmes de santé que le
département des yvelines
je dis vraiment tout parce qu'on a fait
notre benchmark quand même donc on a
regardé ses vagues c'est très très
important est le deuxième appel à
projets qui va arriver en 2020 va être
encore plus ambitieux donc je pense que
c'est une piste qui est plutôt
intéressante
didier deschamps je me tourne vers vous
parce que vous êtes le parlementaire va
directement en contact avec le
gouvernement on sait qu'il ya une
réforme sur les collectivités
territoriales qui est en préparation
est-ce qu'on pourrait intégrer justement
cette réforme de transférer la
compétence santé au département et l ars
et déjà départementale donc je pense
quand on traite de deux sujets serre que
vous avez la rs la rs régionales en île
de france
mais après la ses bras armés dans chacun
des départements oui et quand vous allez
une réunion des services déconcentrés
oui mais j'ai encore quand vous allez à
une réunion aujourd'hui pour trouver du
financement
je travaille sur des choses avec
l'hôpital mignot par exemple je vous
avez systématiquement l'asepam 78 la rs
60 18 qui sont là pour voir le sujet de
vue du financement
franchement qu'il faut faire très
attention à ses sujets l'enjeu est on
l'a très bien dit dans ces exemples
l'enjeu il est une transformation métier
extrêmement importante et aussi une
transformation des systèmes
d'information il ya un très bon exemple
dans les yvelines puisque c'est sur le
j'ai acheté sud en fête qui avait
commencé à travailler sur un système
d'information commun pour que si vous
voulez des enjeux projet c'est de
prendre un exemple si vous essayez
désengorger les urgences
il faut que les urgences le savu et
l'information de quels sont les
professionnels et quelles sont les
maisons de santé qui sont disponibles
pour éventuellement vous accueillir plus
près de chez vous plutôt que d'aller
faire le déplacement jusqu'aux urgences
que si vous disiez tout à l'heure
tout cet investissement informatique
donc il ya une décision dans le cadre du
budget ma santé 2022 qui a été prise
pour harmoniser au moins au niveau
régional il
france en l'occurrence le système
d'information parce que sinon on va
continuer à rester enfin les médecins de
santé sur une coupe unique qui est dr
libre en fête qui commence à distribuer
le la médecine un peu comme ça on y
brise et la médecine
or c'est extrêmement important que les
professionnels de santé se ressaisissent
du sujet après il ya des décisions très
concrètes dans le dans le budget donc on
est en train de discuter en ce moment
donc il sera qui se remplacent le 1er
janvier vous avez alors si le budget
santé 1 pour avoir voir de quoi on parle
c'est obligé globale santé vieillesse et
500 milliards 505 milliards et la partie
santé c'est 200 milliards dans ce budget
de 200 milliards il ya à partir du 1er
janvier la suppression des cotisations
sociales pour les jeunes médecins qui
s'installent pendant deux ans
ça c'est un élément pour que les maisons
de santé se remplissent aussi avec des
jeunes médecins pour qu'il y ait un
renouvellement générationnel qui
s'installe moi je crois pas trop à une
fois les compétences je crois que c'est
en mettant les gens autour de la tam
qu'on arrive à faire des beaux projets
c'est pas pour rien que vous avez un
j'ai acheté sud et à j'ai acheté nord
parce que géographiquement dans les
yvelines
vous avez vraiment deux territoires qui
sont différents et chacun essaye de
coordiner coordonnées pardon dans sa
logique le territoire de santé
et ça ça veut pas se faire sans les
mères sans les agglomérations et sans le
département donc finalement c'est
complémentaire n'y a pas besoin de la
compétence c'est le principe de
subsidiarité qui doit s'appliquer en
fait c'est à dire lorsque les médecins
ils sont toujours au même endroit donc
ce qu'on veut faire c'est la continuité
entre la médecine de ville et l'hôpital
donc il faut à un moment donné aussi
amener des médecins et vous en avez au
samu qui ceux qui participent au tri je
travaille dans un cabinet et je vais
donner des heures aussi au centre de tri
du samu à l'hôpital mignot pour savoir
ce qui se passe mais ça c'est énorme et
ça va générer des choses comme je veux
être salarié où je veux être payé en
frais médical donc faut aussi qu'on ait
des dispositifs qui soit extrêmement
agile lettre je suis je je je partage en
partie mais en partie seulement parce
que je trouve qu'il faut aller plus loin
on est devant un gros problème
un grand défi de désertification un
grand défi d'enjeux du territoire je
pense que c'est très bien
vous l'avez rappelé que chacun reste à
sa place et que chacun se mette autour
de la table je pense qu'il faut aller
plus loin maintenant je pense qu'il faut
se rapprocher de plus en plus des
territoires plus en plus des communes et
c'est une tendance qui est plutôt
naturelle aujourd'hui je pense que il ya
une sorte de décentralisation 2e 3e 4e
étape je sais pas comme on dit de
décentralisation qui fait qu'on va faire
redescendre de plus en plus les sujets
vers le terrain et je pense que c'est
inéluctable
un dernier mot c'est pour ouvrir l'eau
relancer enfin la question par rapport
au parcours santé oms va conclure avec
cette thématique
je me tourne vers beau michel poireau
parce que on sait qu'à à triel-sur-seine
vous êtes juste à côté de l'hôpital des
murs au centre hospitalier aux mureaux
est ce que il y avait il ya ce phénomène
justement où les patients vu qu'ils
n'ont pas de rendez vous médical sur
trials et bien ils vont au centre
hospitalier le plus proche
je ne suis pas en mesure de vous
répondre précisément par contre là les
statistiques de santé montrent que les
médecins triellois jusqu'il ya peu
soignée enfin sur la consommation
médicale à triel les médecins triellois
en 1 / 49%
donc les 50 un autre pour cent sont
faits à l'extérieur
donc il ya ce qu'on appelle un humanisme
voilà juste
justement sur ce parcours de santé pour
conclure il faut y a pas de miracle en
fait sur le parcours de santé c'est
qu'il faut un moment donné que vous ayez
un hôpital territoriales qui soit en
capacité de coordonner les maisons pluri
professionnelle pour ce qu'on appelle la
bobologie en fait ce qui n'est pas une
urgence absolue vital puissent être
traités en médecine de ville dans les
maisons de santé à ce moment là il ne
seriez vous d'accord
merci à tous les trois oui si je puis me
permettre
le statut de maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire avec une contrainte
notamment d'amplitude dans la journée
d'une part mais aussi le week end
enfin le pas dans le samedi d'une part
et puis le projet de santé de l'équipe
réponde en grande partie à ce traitement
de la bobologie
j'en veux pour exemple un médecin est
venu expliquer à ses collègues triellois
dans son cabinet dès lors qu'il y à un
certain nombre de personnes qui viennent
avec de la fièvre dans le courant de
l'hiver
donc il déclenche un plan qu'ils ont mis
au point un plan grippe donc un des
généralistes ne prend plus que des gens
au fur et à mesure sans rendez vous et
c'est en vue de la grippe donc ça fait
aussi partie de l'offre qui permet de
faire la jonction avec le désengorgement
des urgences etc
merci on arrivera au terme de cette
émission merci à tous les trois d'être
venu sur ce plateau
et puis des missions spéciales de télé
78 se poursuit à l'université des
mairies
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]